Littlefinger is the player in the
shadows he's definitely playing the game
of Thrones and to what end
only Littlefinger knows but he is moving
to pieces around he's manipulating
events he thrives on chaos because in
chaos there's opportunity for
advancement so he creates chaos while
pretending or feigning to be everybody's
friend
to be always helpful always smiling
always joking he's very very charming
it becomes apparent to Lisa who is
obsessed with peter baelish
and has loved him since she was a girl
and he was a foster Ling at Riverrun
that peter's feelings toward Sansa are
not entirely paternal they're partially
paternal because Littlefinger has very
mixed feelings here too I mean sometimes
he sees Sansa and she's the daughter he
never had the daughter that he might
have had would cat if he and cat had
been married as he as he dreamed when he
was a small boy living in her father's
castle and was so madly in love with her
but at other times he detaches himself
from that and he he's less Peter and
he's more Littlefinger and she's just
another piece in the game of thrones
she's just another valuable piece that
he's going to use to get what he wants
and at yet other times she's not Cavs
daughter she's like young cat
she's his teenage fantasies returned
again and then his feelings toward her
or sexual and romantic and those
feelings overcome him at the moment when
he sees Sansa in the snow so beautiful
in the snow building the snow castle
Winterfell it reminds him very much of
the young cat and he reacts that in a by
kissing her
and unfortunately Lysa sees that which
is not something she wanted to see up to
now Sansa has been a piece that other
people have moved about the board to
achieve their own goals using her
discarding her using a fur for a
different purpose you know you're gonna
marry Joffrey no you're gonna marry
Horace you're gonna marry Tyrion
she is beginning to at least try to
understand how she can play the game of
Thrones and be not a piece but a player
with her own goals
and moving other pieces around and she's
not a warrior like Rob John snow
she's not even a wild child like Arya
she can't fight with swords axes she
can't raise armies but she has her wits
the same as Littlefinger has